foreign
s have questions behind them that I'm
not voicing right so I asked you about
you and Paul and your interactions and
how fiction was viewed as a gift or
maybe even a an obligation and I'm
asking in part because I'm experimenting
with fiction
I get energized by it there's so I'm
paying attention to there's something
there
there's something there for me
personally
but at times I wonder am I being
self-indulgent like is this
and and a lot of what I've done in life
has been from a place of moral
obligation uh and dealing with really in
some cases let's just say in working
with Therapeutics for things like
treatment resistant depression and of
Life anxiety with people who have
terminal illnesses it's very heavy
and so I've wanted to maybe explore how
I can try to transmit truths that are
hidden kind of like Easter eggs in this
fictional landscape
but that's maybe another form of
resistance that's coming up for me like
should I really be doing this is this
just self-indulgent you know am I just
like playing with toys in a corner and
not doing something that's meaningful I
don't think it is self-indulgent at all
Michelle I can answer that from two
questions one is looking at it from the
inside out you as as a Creator as a
writer as doing something like that
why is it important I think for our own
soul yeah forget about anybody else that
even sees it yeah you know if you don't
do that it's like we are when we have an
idea we are like pregnant with that idea
and that idea has a life of its own
right it wants to be born and if we
don't let it be born we'll pay the price
one way or another but I also believe
that that creativity a dance a song
whatever you're doing with nfts and
eight different houses or something
whatever you know I don't know what it
is at all but I know that the world
needs it yeah you know and some Cosmic
way
I I'm definitely a believer that there's
another dimension of reality The Muse or
God's Consciousness or whatever that
wants to bring
Beauty and Truth into the world and it
comes through you and me and other peop
we're sort of conduits for the
co-creators of it or whatever so that
there is a cause it's not self-indulgent
it would be the opposite it's really an
obligation I think we have we all have
an obligation to bring that forth
whatever whatever it is and
I can't prove that that's doing any good
I mean you look at the world it looks
pretty screwed up you know yeah but I do
think that it's not self-indulgent at
all to do that and it really is
important I think to believe in to
believe yeah you know
thank you for for sharing that and I
also as you were talking I was thinking
about
the very fundamental piece of getting so
much energy from doing what I'm doing
because that energy transfers outside of
a writing session so it can be applied
to many many other things so it's
providing overall to me more fuel for
everything that I can do
so that is also
a reason in and of itself to do it